era presidente de la federación francesa
de fútbol desde 2011 pero durante su
tiempo en la cima Noel le trae no ha
sido ajeno a los escándalos
en 2019 grupos ante discriminación
pidieron alegrar que dimitiera después
de que dijera que los partidos ya no
deberían detenerse cuando hubiera cantos
homófobos está pidiendo los árbitros que
no paren más sus partidos es un error
parar un partido quiero que los árbitros
dejen de parar partidos unos meses más
tarde afirmó que el racismo no existe en
el mundo del fútbol
en vísperas del mundial de 2022 este
hombre de 81 años también fue criticado
por su excesivo apoyo a Qatar El golpe
final mofarse de Zidane figura
emblemática del fútbol francés en una
entrevista concedida a la radio francesa
legrae declaró que ni siquiera habría
contestado la llamada sisian se hubiera
puesto en contacto con él a raíz de
estos comentarios el jefe del fútbol
francés recibió una avalancha de
críticas incluida la de la ministra
nacional de deportes
parece como si estuviéramos una
competición es partido tras partido
punto tras punto
creo que ya ha fracasado en su tarea de
representar a la federación francesa de
fútbol
el gobierno puso en marcha una auditoría
de la federación y le grae fue convocado
una audiencia El martes la federación
francesa de fútbol comunicó del
presidente abandonó el cargo el cual
quedará con el vicepresidente philippe
diálogo como interino hasta que se
comunican los resultados de la auditoría
encargada